das ist mein thema ist das ein appell
begangen die
benzinpreise steigen oranien vor allem
der staat verdient ja da bedient ja
daran dass ich immer dass ich immer
teurer tangos und das trifft natürlich
vor allem auch die geringverdiener ich
denke zum beispiel im sommer also
coroner lässt vielleicht nach jetzt
möchte die normale deutsche familie in
den urlaub fahren das kann sie sich ja
kaum mehr leisten wenn sie nicht gerade
sehr wenn sie nicht doppelverdiener sind
oder dreifach verdiener die normale
familie kann sich das nicht mehr leisten
weil sich der benzinpreis glaube ich
fast verdoppelt hat ganz abgesehen davon
mache mir auch sorgen die heizkosten
denn die die
nebenkostenabrechnungen kommt meistens
im sommer also will holzhaus urlaub
doppelt haben dafür doppel gala von
dreifach strompreise das kommt alles in
der nebenkostenabrechnung für die
meisten menschen so irgendwie mai/juni
wenn sie eigentlich nur urlaub fahren
wollen und wie sollen sich dass die
deutschen leisten können vor allem die
senioren die allein erziehenden
studenten kinderreiche familien oder ihr
wissen zum teil zwischen 500 und 600
euro nachzahlen das haut in die
familienkasse doch wahnsinnig hinein vor
allem also ich meine die senioren mit
der kleinen geringen rente können sich
noch überhaupt nicht leisten und da
denke ich da jetzt alle parteien reden
jetzt darüber dass man irgendwie helfen
was unterstützen was auch hinter zum
beispiel fordert forderte unterstützung
entlastung steuerentlastung auch vor
allem ist benzin muss natürlich runter
da muss der staat einfach was verzichten
man weiß ja dass 64 cent glaublich
steuern
nimmt der staat von dem von benzin wir
haben die tollsten benzinkosten glaube
ich fast weltweit irgendwie wir haben
die wir haben auf jeden fall die
höchsten strompreise weltweit und dann
muss ich auch sagen ein bisschen der
heuchelei was die politik dann macht man
auch da wird dann machen sie macht den
bock zum gärtner weil auf der einen
seite haben sie denn der liegt völlig
chaotische energiewende vollzogen haben
atomenergie abgestellt und jetzt sagen
es irgendwie hier wir müssen wir müssen
jetzt ein heizkostenzuschuss 175 euro
für diejenigen die mehr geld bekommen
das auch noch ein paket von 710
millionen euro den wir zahlen das heißt
wir zahlen den ihre fehler sie machen
einen historischen fehler nach dem
anderen verliert auch noch lächeln haben
sie auch dafür haben sie auch mehr
steuereinnahmen außer energie aber der
große und bleibende widerspruch dieser
regierung ist dass sie ja das auch will
sie will ja energie verteuern damit
weniger verbraucht wird das ja die
absicht einer gern doch das ist aber so
da ja auch so bleiben denn auf der
anderen seite müssen sie aber dem die
sich das nicht leisten können einen
ausgleich geben dass es gibt immer ein
hin und her dann wird das fängt jetzt
gerade erst an dann wird's immer rat
augenblick hat ja gesagt dass wenn man
den preis senkt dann würden vor allem
die reichen davon profitieren das will
ich ja ganz schön zynisch aber wenn man
ja ein mann die die die mineralölsteuer
gesenkt kriegen alle was also auch die
es gar nicht braucht man muss also dann
schon sozial ausgewählt auf die gruppen
zugehen design medizin ist es schwierig
soll ich an der tankstelle sagen so ist
mein vermögenssituation des ja
kilometerpauschale dem weg also die ja
normal
es ist die stunde in der der staat
darüber nachdenken muss das wäre so
langsam in dem andern lassen muss und
handeln und zwar jetzt dass leute geld
zurückkriegt so also wir können ja
natürlich kroner maßnahmen mit 350
milliarden euro
finanzieren und kann mal eben ganz
schnell 200 milliarden freigeschaltet
noch stolz als finanzminister bei cola
toll da war ich stolz dass das möglich
ist dass wir das konnten dass wir dann
nicht pleitegehen keine lampen mehr
angehen züge weiterfahren also dass man
am nächsten tag nachdem man zwei
milliarden euro frei geschaltet hat noch
im gleichen wohlstandsland leben kann
wenn das aber war es dann müssen jetzt
auch große summen bereitgestellt werden
um den menschen diese kosten
auszugleichen wer soll es denn sonst
machen und ich darf noch mal ganz kurz
dann in steuergeld hat den leuten ja
sowieso schon mal gehört also es ist
nicht so toll aber steuergeld ich muss
mich auch selber immer noch mal daran
erinnern weil politiker ganz so tun als
wäre es ihr eigenes geld man jetzt
umgehen das ist aber unser geld und wer
könnte ja auch auf den gedanken kommen
zu sagen wir haben steuern hohe steuern
bezahlt und das war so eine art
sicherungsanlage für notzeiten nämlich
jetzt wo alles teurer wird und jetzt
möchte ich ein stück des geldes zurück
und das wird ja in die richtung laufen
über ihren zuschuss da an zuschuss bloß
nicht nur fehler bekämpfen und zu geben
dass die energiewende für simple tor das
man natürlich strom und
gas nicht endlos teurer machen kann um
die leute zum sparen zu bringen und zum
zum umdenken zu bringen diese erpressung
genau genommen dass erpressung aber
trotzdem
aber trotzdem ist es doch eine farce
dass die politik sich jetzt darstellt
und sagt wissen die große retter mehrere
schützen jetzt die steuertöpfen über den
leuten aus denn das geld haben aber
eigentlich haben sie die diese
grundproblematik selbst initiiert und
implementiert durch eine falsche
energiepolitik hat durch
diese politik politik darf man nicht
sagen finde ich das ist mir zu
allgemeinen werden müssen dann auch bei
dieser regierung genau hingucken da
erkennt man doch jetzt bruchlinien und
es ist ja nicht die aufgabe des
finanzministers
ausgaben vorzuschlagen ganz im gegenteil
tut er aber lindner sagt dann müssen wir
was für die für die autofahrer tun und
hier und da was tun um die energiekosten
auszugleichen es wäre eigentlich aufgabe
entweder des arbeits und sozialministers
oder noch mehr des wirtschaftsministers
aber harbeck habe ich den eindruck sieht
sich gar nicht als wirtschaftsminister
sieht sich als klimaminister das was da
passiert ist seine grob gesprochen seine
absicht energie muss teurer werden damit
weniger verbraucht wird und dass da
leute darunter leiden ist nicht sein
erstes anliegen und der kanzler schläft
der könnte natürlich auch längst mal
aufgetaucht sein und dazu ein wort
gesagt haben tut er aber nicht das heißt
dass sport vor sich hin und die größte
überraschung ist muss ich noch mal sagen
lindner und fdp da waren die früher nie
und
polieren
so langsam gar nichts
aber traurig getrommel nochmals der
kernthese die fahne ich nämlich so
wichtig niemand sollte in deutschland
frieren und das ist ja eigentlich auch
schon so grund.de neben dem benzin dass
er wirklich schon familien auch darüber
nachdenken wann sie jetzt heizen wie
lange sie die heizung laufen lassen weil
es so teuer wird was kann man dagegen
tun ja man kann zb wir reden ja von
menschen mit geringfügigen einkommen ja
also man kann zum beispiel das wohngeld
erhöhen und dort mit einen
heizkostenzuschuss zum beispiel
frankreich frankreich hat auch einen
heizkostenzuschuss einen einmaligen an
seine bürger verschickt die also wenig
verdienen und man muss das auch mal
menschlich sehen ja also der
durchschnittsrentner
hat so eine rente zwischen 13 und 14 100
euro
13 14 100 euro es gibt auch im neunten
teil ja ja da muss aber davon miete
zahlen darf man muss vielleicht sein
handy zahlen damit muss er sich auch was
essen kaufen können und was vielleicht
zum arzt mit denen öffentliche
verkehrsmittel fahren können man macht
sich das kaum bewusst da wie knapp das
geld für millionen menschen in
deutschland ist der wir die wir hier
sitzen wir werden erhöhte benzinpreise
und und heizkosten wahrscheinlich
irgendwie wegstecken können sagen ja
okay das vielleicht hört dass auch mal
irgendwann auf aber mein gedanke geht an
die menschen die wirklich ganz wenig
haben stehen soziale euro sind schon
viele solcher ganz viel geld wie
entscheiden darüber ob ich mir ob ich
mir eine wurstsemmel kaufe oder ob ich
mir vielleicht eine zeitung kaufen
müssen die müssen ja es gibt ja so
kleine kosten den damit gemacht haben
vor allem brauche ich auch was zum
sparen wenn irgendwas passiert und das
gilt auch für kinderreiche familien und
es gilt für alleinerziehende und es gilt
auch für studenten die haben ein kleines
bafög oder eine kleine unterstützung von
ihren eltern
nicht so handy die heizkosten
nachzahlungen stellerin also das ist
wirklich das finde ich wirklich
schwierig und ich verfolge das alle
parteien nach lösungen suchen und alle
reden linthe ganz besonders ich finde
aber das muss jetzt geschehen und nicht
nur darüber reden und dann diskutieren
und vielleicht und wie auch immer sonne
es muss jetzt etwas geschehen damit die
leute auch ein bisschen optimismus haben
nach dieser schweren corona ja nichts
passieren weil das wort caron auch mal
sagen wir eine brauchen die leute
hoffnung und eine aussicht auch mal dass
es besser wird und ich finde wir sind
dann wirklich noch eine
solidargemeinschaft und auch da muss man
sagen kanzler auf waren ja also ich muss
mal langsam annehmen was ich sage das
ganz schlimm dass er leute werden sich
auf und stürzen ich würde ich wäre sogar
für eine heizung so lief menschen die
das brauchen ja auch persönlich für
menschen die wir es brauchen ja da hast
du den zahlen liegt dabei oberhand
ich denke nach
das hilft den richtigen aber es schützt
die falschen so zu sagen wenn man das
jetzt täten also quasi es bei mir bei
dir ich meine bei 980 würden von kriegen
ja sie haben von 980 zwischenrufen
rechnung seit 1960 zwischenrufen das nur
mal
[Gelächter]
2002 1000 euro von dem man nie im leben
zu wenig
es war nur ein mist aber was ich meine
ist wir müssen aufpassen dass er nicht
durch persönliches quasi soziales
engagement
diejenigen aus der pflicht nimmt die in
der pflicht werden nämlich politiker die
über die ausgaben verfügen und jetzt sag
ich's halt dann mal muss christian
lindner das jetzt ja und muss dann zum
robert habeck sagen es macht mir jetzt
so wenn er so weiter macht es ja
irgendwann auch bundeskanzler der
lindenallee ja dann aber für welche
partei hat jetzt das wort das es ihm
vielleicht auch ein
tolles anliegen und es ist ein
großartige idee von ihm zu sagen und
auch mutig wir müssen denen helfen die
jetzt unsere hilfe brauchen aber da
müssen ja auch taten folgen also ich mir
auch sagen mir kommen mittlerweile er
sofort wer die politik auch ein bisschen
abgehoben vor allem auch wenn wir auf
die grünen schauen ja auch mit regieren
deswegen meine frage an sie herr
friedrich wie es ist denn jetzt
eigentlich man muss ja sagen das ist ja
schon eine gewisse klientel politik auch
also vor allem wenn man sich die grünen
an schaumberg anschaut der lieber
klimaminister ist als
wirtschaftsminister ist das vielleicht
das problem der ganzen sache warum sich
dem nicht mit schwung und werf
angenommen wird dass die politik einfach
schon anderen sphären schwebt ja
absolute sind haben eine gewisse hybris
ja machen den politik versuche natürlich
ihre wählergruppe zu befriedigen aber
gesamtheitliche lösungen werden nicht
gefunden also den linden machtpolitik
damit er wieder gewählt wird weil jetzt
natürlich angst haben weil sie die
impfpflicht doch geführt haben dass ich
bei der nächsten bundestagswahl
rausgekegelt werden und jeder guckt und
da sind wiedergewählt wird einmal
deutlich glaube nicht dass sie eine
hybris haben ich glaube langsam schon
die stecken in den anfängen ich habe er
den einen das ist ein stümper regierung
wir haben da bin ich bei ihr haben ja
miterlebt wie die genesenen
spannenden anderen haus glaube ich nach
wie vor dass lauterbach dahinter steckt
und nicht herr wieder hat er will am
auftrag für lauterbach gemacht aber das
nicht mein problem ist
ob man schon prima ticket muss ich schon
begründen denn eisen im feuer aber was
hinterher passiert ist das habeck der
klimaminister nämlich die gesamte
bauindustrie schockiert hat indem er die
subventionen für ökologisches bauen von
einfachen anderen gestoppt hat da waren
häuslebauer standen fassungslos davor
baufirmen und architekten die ganze
branche der hat gar nicht begriffen was
er da tut also das sind die ersten
anfänge dieser koalition übrigens hat
rot grün mit geschulter auch mal so
angefangen nach hause ich sagen doch
dort machte er nicht geruckelt da hat
nichts funktioniert das sind anfänger
einer koalition das einzige was bisher
kommt wieder drauf was bisher rund läuft
ist die fdp muss ich sagen
[Gelächter]
für die fdp von hans ulrich wolter die
entschuldigung
bei uns haben eine ganz kurze
unterbrechungen dann geht es weiter mit
gerhard schröder und was tauscht uns
eigentlich über den altkanzler sagt